grown-ups I guess the the real question
is can you be friends with a guy that he
wouldn't sleep with you
I'm not doing that again
I I want to say yeah I really want to
say yeah you can but I don't think so I
think if you're a try if you're an
attractive woman and you've got
substance about you even forget the
substance if you're an attractive woman
if you really wanted to you could sleep
with any of your friends whereas we're
the ones who say I don't want to push
that line you know we're such good
friends
they're not afraid to break that line
one bit apparently you're what 21. yeah
yeah
any of them you're attractive woman any
of any of them yeah trust me yeah I
haven't
my friends are my friends